hello this
is um ee38 my name is dennis allison
and uh today we have uh stephanie lep as
a
uh a speaker um this is
uh now uh november 21st
2020. the um
the context right today is we have just
completed
the presidential election which was won
by joe biden
and disputed by president trump
and uh things are still in
a bit of a a mess we're in the middle of
a
pandemic and um
[Music]
life is uh is continuing um in any case
uh
today stephanie is going to talk about
some of the work she's done she's a palo
alto artist
um i found her
uh through my friend jeff goodfellow
who runs a list of
things that you want to look at for some
of us
and uh she apparently had been
interviewed or at least
someone in a newspaper in england
had uh seen her work and
had written a short article uh which
jeff had
snipped out and sent around to his uh
his friends
so uh this is actually motivated by
a newspaper article published in england
about
the u.s uh artist stephanie
i wonder what article it was interesting
uh if you wish stephanie i could send
you a copy
yeah i'm curious i also this this you
might not know about me i'm also
actually a stanford graduate
so this is a this is a sweet little you
know kind of a homecoming here
well that and also you work you work for
you've been working at uh at the uh um
institute for the future yes and
this is a an sri spin out
of some time ago um right so they've
done work with them
and it's uh it's one of the the uh
uh premier organizations for predicting
the future
so you're a futurist as well as an
artist which is
well some of us think that that's uh the
normal way things should
be yeah they go hand in hand um in any
case
uh what jeff said and what
with the article i saw said is that you
have been uh
using some of the the recent technology
for inserting uh people
uh into uh videos and having them say
what you want them to say
um this uh this sort of agit prop
stuff was widely used during the
election by
all sorts of people uh i think perhaps
the most
widely distributed that i saw was uh
a couple of the tapes of joe biden
that had been edited to make him look
like he was a
bumbling idiot and um
they they were successful
in making that it looked that way though
uh
certainly not uh uh not keeping the
truth
the truth is sort of the casualty of all
of this
it used to be that you'd argue that a
video was not
something that could be could be faked
uh but we have managed to prove that
isn't true
yes so anyhow why don't you tell us a
little bit about what it is you're doing
why you're doing it and
we'll see what happens yeah well thank
you dennis
happy to be here and happy to be kind of
back at stanford
um yeah so the project is called deep
reckonings
and i can yeah i can i can talk a little
bit about where
where it comes from so for the last
for the last couple years i have been
producing a podcast called
reckonings that explores how
we change our hearts and minds so every
episode
tells the story of someone who made some
kind of
transformation um from you know a deeply
conservative congressman who made uh
what he would call
a spiritual conversion on climate change
all the way to a white supremacist who
managed
to transcend a life of hate all the way
to
um the the architect of facebook's
business model
who realized at one point he was
addicted to his phone
and had a reckoning and has since
devoted his life to tackling technology
addiction
so it's been a you could call it a
a motley crew of characters but um but
the through line has really just been an
exploration of this question you know
how do
people change and how do people change
in
ways that connect to or scale into
broader social and political change and
from the early days of the show i've had
this
this kind of wish list of guests um
you know of people and and really public
figures who who i thought that their
personal transformation would especially
you know scale into or translate into
broad-based social change
you know when we when we think about or
when i think about social change i
i think about i think about social
movements i think about the civil rights
movement i think about
you know having to have large numbers of
people agitating
for social change but you know the
question can also
come up you know well who are the fewest
number of people
that if they changed you know like
if charles coke had a crisis of
conscience
that would literally change the climate
trajectory of our planet
and so i i have this kind of wish list
of guests you know
um on very unrealistic wish list of
guests and i was kind of fantasizing
about this
fake film i was going to make about
charles koch's personal transformation
and how it changed the world
and then i discovered the phenomenon
of deep fakes which i imagine all of you
are familiar with deep fakes being
you know a video that can make it look
like anyone is saying or doing
anything although they never said it or
did it so
you know think me with my fantasy about
this film about charles coke i realized
you could
actually do this you can actually put
you know have charles coke or have
anyone have a crisis of conscience and i
and so i decided to do an audio
prototype
on reckonings i ended up going with the
pope
so it's an imaginary reckoning with pope
francis i wrote a script and i had a
voice actor perform it and i
had no idea what listeners were going to
say i had never
aired fiction on the show and
um and to my surprise
people loved it and i even heard from
survivors of clergy sex abuse who
knowing that it was fiction found it
really helpful to hear the
imaginary pope say the kinds of things
that they would love to hear the real
pope say
so that that was that was
that was released in early 2019 so then
it just became a matter of finding the
tech partner and finding the funding so
deep reckonings which which just
launched a couple weeks ago is
the culmination of a years-long
exploration
of how people change and it is a series
of
explicitly marked deep fake videos that
imagine
mark zuckerberg brett kavanaugh and alex
jones
having a reckoning and it is absolutely
explicit
that the videos are fake partly because
i'm not interested in deceiving anybody
but also because
to me that's that's part of the the
power of this medium is that you can
know that it's fake
and it still influences you like these
survivors of clergy subsidies you can
know that you're
listening or watching or reading fiction
and it still moves you
and and the question i'm exploring with
this project or one of the
kind of the key question is you know how
might we use
our synthetic selves to elicit
our better angels and
just to conclude the i guess the kind of
like the two intentions of the project
are one two um you know we're all we're
all
we've we're all very used to the deny
and deflect playbook
um in the trump era you know of of how
base of how
public figures kind of traditionally
respond to credible accusations of
wrongdoing
um by denying and deflecting and so one
intention is just to create a new
playbook
um to create something that's more
beautiful and more powerful and more
i mean you could say the more manly it's
just more stunning
than what we're used to uh so that
you know so that to make critical
self-reflection look
beautiful and ultimately to make more
room for ourselves to
to grow in public so that's that's the
first intention and the second intention
of course i'm working with a very
provocative medium here
and and also a very extraordinarily
powerful medium and
and i and i do believe there is
tremendous potential to use
synthetic media in not just ethical ways
but but but but in socially benevolent
ways and so
with deep reckonings i'm also looking to
to to kind of carve out and
and expand you know the the the
potential
of what we might call pro-social
synthetic media
i think that's fascinating uh i think
you're in a you're you're operating in a
in a long-standing tradition of magic
prop
uh material and uh broadsides and that
sort of thing
but with uh a tremendous amount of
uh new media uh supporting you
uh the fact that you can make something
that looks seamless
is uh is really very impressive
very radical yeah yeah
so how how how has it has been received
by the people that you have
um uh produced cameos of what did
zuckerberg say
have you have you heard have you heard
from me i have not i mean my goal my
design
challenge to myself as potentially
impossible as
this sounds was to create something that
that if mark zuckerberg were to see it
would move him to say
you know that's now that's hot like that
is the me that i want to be
um so i very so i very much uh
um yeah how possible that is but but
that that
like my design brief to myself was to
produce something
that would of course speak to the
critics of this person but would also
not alienate the person yeah i have not
heard from mark zuckerberg i know that
chris cox i had
proxies for each of them because i
actually
i actually would love for each of them
to see this
and but none of them are available on
twitter or
very accessible in general so for each
of them i identified a proxy
of someone who people could tweet at to
share this with that person so for mark
zuckerberg it's chris cox
who's the chief product officer at
facebook and also a long time friend of
mark zuckerberg's
i know chris cox is aware of it um
for brett kavanaugh it's it's someone
it's a man named nick rosenkrantz who's
also part
a member of the federalist society and
he also happens to be a broadway
producer
and he's also pretty active on twitter
so i figured he's someone i could get to
who probably has a personal connection
and
has an affinity for theater so um
i don't know you asked for yes yeah and
then alex jones
the proxy who's as unavailable if not
more is
joe rogan because the the the video of
alex jones is actually
him and alex jones has his record has
his imaginary reckoning
on the joe rogan experience and joe
rogan has actually
kind of tried to get alex to kind of
come
clean when he's had him on the show and
actually alex jones
just went on joe rogan a couple weeks
ago and people were up in arms because
spotify just acquired
joe rogan's podcast and so there's this
question of should
spotify like prevent
joe rogan from being able to invite alex
jones on who of course when he went on
was
casting doubt on vaccines that was out
was being himself
and so there's kind of this debate of
like should spotify
prevent or not prevent joe rogan from
having alex jones or any other guest for
that matter
but the deep reckonings it's like those
are not the only options
what if spotify and joe rogan could
engage alex jones in a completely
different kind
of conversation right having him or
like letting him say whatever he wants
and banning him are just not the only
two options
and that's that's kind of part of what
i'm trying to explore
although that's how it's being framed
right in in the debate
um so yeah so
do you think you think this is really in
some sense a new genre that you're
creating
of uh a political messaging
as you're you're you're you're
you're creating the world as it ought to
be
in your eyes and presenting that with
the
actors of the current world then that's
that is kind of what is
what is new here we've we've seen plenty
of deep fakes used
to parody people to make them look worse
right and so yeah this is an exploration
of
what if we use this medium to make us
look more
morally courageous or more whatever
you know be envision the change we wish
to see i mean i can imagine
my husband happens to be in addiction
medicine and i can imagine
you know working with an someone who
struggles with addiction
just to script you know a deep fake of
their sober self
in the future talking to themselves now
encouraging themselves onto the path of
recovery i mean there's all kinds of
you can but yeah that that's kind of the
new the area i'm trying to carve out
here is
using deep fakes to envision and
ultimately elicit
the the the reality we want to see
yeah well maybe we can do something
about global warming while we're at it
sounds good let's do it
so materials you've done are uh
you know i mean you're clearly you're
clearly a modern
uh artist which is to say you're on the
internet somewhere
you probably ought to tell us where
because i think that people would uh
would be interested i know that you have
uh your uh
infinite lunchbox.com site
yes so yeah infinite lunchbox.com
is kind of my my very simple home
it's just it's pretty much just a splash
page with
links to to other work and then deep
reckonings.com is where you can find
deep reckonings the project okay and
yeah then
you have youtube a youtube channel as
well i do so there is an infinite
lunchbox youtube channel
and i think the url is just youtube.com
c slash infinite lunchbox
and uh but but yeah infinite
lunchbox.com
links to everything but infinite
lunchbox of the youtube channel is
is is is basically just a
kind of a a helping
people kind of see this political moment
in a way that
is a little heterodox like not
quite in line with kind of what we hear
in the news
um a little heterodox and and and
hopeful
um so yeah if uh
it's it's it's i consider it kind of a
yeah a heterodox and hopeful take
on current events on what's going on in
this moment
what i like about what you're doing uh
is the fact that uh you're doing it and
you're you're making uh your
belief and your understanding of the
current situation
what needs to be done uh available to
other people to see
through the eyes of the people who are
causing the problem or
whatever i think i think it's it's it's
a it's an interesting uh
uh conundrum and a very i think a very
powerful
uh metaphor for uh for today
um and i'm not even sure what what is
harder for people to swallow
the idea of deep fakes being used in a
pro-social way or the idea of
not even just letting these men
apologize
because that that's hard enough as it is
like letting them
kind of have their reckoning but but
letting them
like take leadership on the um precisely
on the issues that
they have you know um done so much
damage
around so um i think that's actually
maybe even the
harder thing for people about this
project kind of what makes it the most
most subversive is is yeah is
is is is is kind of letting the tyrant
be the hero or
really just transcending those
categories all together
yeah i think so yeah so how did you get
the idea
is it just out of the blue you saw you
saw the
uh some of the postings about uh make
your own um
uh sex film or something and uh oh well
i was
i i had this fantasy of this you know
charles coke film that i wanted to make
but i just didn't know
i didn't know it was possible to do it
and then in 2017 i discovered
it's like i had the idea before i knew
about the technology
which in a way i don't know there's
something a little comforting
i mean and science fiction does this all
the time obviously but there's something
i don't know somehow comforting about
kind of coming up with ideas of things
we want to do before
it just makes it seem like our capacity
to do it is is really coming from
somewhere it's like it's not just coming
out of nowhere
um yeah it just makes yeah
which obviously you know we are creating
these tools so
it's coming from us but um yeah there's
something almost a little comforting
about the fact that i
i'd had that the idea it doesn't that it
didn't just come from
the technology itself it's like we have
visions of things that we want to do or
inspirations to do things and our
capacity
to do them kind of like catches up with
with with the dreams
so how do you how do you feel about the
uh
you know the fuss going on right now
about um
uh well
they're all sorts of things they're you
know the section
230 uh restrictions on uh
on material uh attempts to uh
to minimize the access of uh
of uh internet uh uh forums to
people who um don't meet certain
criteria the
you know the real censorship issues
they're
uh people worrying about uh uh privacy
and uh
applying privacy rules to public figures
which
may or may not be an acceptable thing uh
they're
the the the ability to write things
uh and present information on the
internet is in
some ways being challenged yeah
and is that a good thing or a bad thing
i personally think it's quite a bad
thing but that's uh
uh that's an issue well yeah why don't
you lay out your
your position i'd be curious i think i
think that the internet is
uh and the wild west that we have now
is uh is fine i don't like the idea of
censorship at all
on the other hand i would really like
people to be
a bit uh smarter and
functional a little bit better yeah
i mean the this is obviously its own
could be its own many hours long
conversation
i mean i i might just leave it as simple
as um
you know it kind of just depends on the
goal of each forum
you know what is the goal of facebook
or twitter or reddit or hn
or you know any of these forums and
and and and you just have to yeah i
think it just it
there's got to be a lot of clarity
around the goal and then once you know
your goal
then under what circumstances do we
regulate what kinds of speech
in ways that are conducive to achieving
that goal
so you know yeah it's it's it's
um i think we can i don't know i i think
kind of mark zuckerberg like um he'll
just
he'll make these kinds of comments about
kind of like free you know free speech
you know gotta protect free speech and
um and uh but but you know but if his
goal
is community building connection i don't
really know what his goal is i don't
you know he's got to get some clarity
which i don't
want to assume he doesn't
finding out what you want to buy and
helping you buy it
oh yes that's that's that's the real
goal in some sense
yes um i don't know the um
the degree to which uh you were
surveilled for that purpose is fairly
high
yeah you know actually you know i'm
gonna actually quote
um the imaginary zuckerberg here on this
one so
this is directly from his imaginary
reckoning he says
he says the question isn't how to remove
dangerous content while maintaining the
widest definition of free speech
possible
or whether facebook should be an arbiter
of truth facebook already
is an arbiter of truth the question is
how to make editorial decisions that our
users can trust
and that fulfill our actual mission
which goes
beyond free speech
yeah well we'd like to know what that
actual mission is
[Laughter]
that's uh i mean that's that's that's
actually kind of a
part of the next part of his reckoning
but i won't i won't spoil it for
for people they can go and watch the
video that's
that's that's that's really good i know
you know we're talking about
you know signing up things i in in a
sense i i
um one of the internet icons is john
perry barlow who wrote
the the a manifesto about the internet
which
basically was to provide
a a place where uh ideas are
presented without without
any restriction and that
that's always seemed to me to be
a a very good a very good thing
it means the things that you would like
not to be widely available are made
widely available
and uh it also has shown that at least
in our society
people are much more interested in
things that i would prefer them not to
be interested in than i would
than than they yeah
they are but to introduce any
restriction causes
uh major problems with uh with things
that
shouldn't be restricted i mean for
example you know uh
uh the word breast
was at one point in somebody's this is a
should not appear list and so all of the
material about breast cancer
and fundraising for breast cancer was
all of a sudden removed
wow yeah and you know similar similarly
uh
you know there are uh tremendous
impacts uh unexpected
that uh have to be dealt with
so i don't know yeah i guess i just
i mean i think there will kind of always
be little
wild wild west places so it's really
just a matter of like what do you
your platform want to be and if the
problem is that
um you know like when we let people say
whatever they want we get a
bunch of white supremacy and you know
xenophobia well then there's there's
other problems that we need to work on
that aren't going to be solved with you
know with like
speech moderation
yeah the the the uh the current
situation
in china is interesting in that uh the
uh there basically is a uh
tracking on basically everything you
access
in in here assuming you're a chinese
person
and uh you're you have a score that this
is
goodness so if you if you look at bad
things you get a bad score
if you look at good things or you say
good things you get a good score
and uh then the uh the karma that you
get in that fashion
is used to uh determine whether or not
you get
to to uh to do a lot of other things
and the pervasiveness of surveillance is
uh
is pretty good and uh so
things are really changing quite
substantially in that regard
[Music]
and i don't know i don't know whether
that's something which uh
we'll adopt here in the u.s or not um
certainly there are people who seem to
feel that that's a that's a good idea
that the the surveillance is
to keep to keep track of everything you
see and do
and make that available to determine
whether what you're doing is uh
uh i don't know quote good unquote yeah
the question is who who gets to who has
access to everything you say and do and
who is making that decision
yes that's an interesting question it's
probably somebody you would just assume
not
but that's a different matter yes yeah
but it's it's it's it's interesting that
uh
that at least at this point in time you
can do what it amounts to
a fictional recreation of somebody
and their attitudes yeah and uh have
them
have them behave did you want to did you
want to take a you have do you have a
clip that you could show here and
give us a hint as to what's going on
sure
um would that that would oh i guess
so i would share my screen um sure
maybe i'll share um
why don't i share the shortest one or i
can also just share the trailer
because that's that's actually i think
the trailer probably is the right thing
here
okay i i think it uh
i think you can share your screen
hey everyone uh i i know the boycotts
and resignations and everything were
tough on our company and
i've been reflecting and i want to give
you an
honest response
when we launched facebook to the world
it was the glory days of social media
social media was this liberating force
that was going to democratize access to
information
and give everyone a voice and and it's
the truth is we did that
we gave small publishers the same
sophisticated tools the big guys had
and we allowed citizens to speak out
against oppressive regimes
and we enabled people to be more
creative and entrepreneurial
but the other truth is there was a bad
side
to all of this the small publishers we
empowered ended up including
hateful propagandists like alex jones
our algorithms fueled ethnic violence in
myanmar and sri lanka
this is not actually the trailer sorry
people on our platform have become more
okay so let's try that one more time
well actually i think i think it what i
was looking for was an exemplar
and this i think is adequate it's it
shows
exactly where you're going it's uh it's
really quite
uh quite impressive okay i can either
we can just leave it leave it there or i
can let's leave it let's leave it there
and continue the conversation perhaps
the sound is is is is remarkably like uh
like uh zuckerberg speaks how did you do
that
so the sound is actually a voice actor
although it is possible to do
um i did not do synthetic audio but it
is possible to feed the ai
you know enough data enough of the
person's voice
to create a model and then you then just
feed it script and it says the words in
that person's
voice yeah i think i think the voice
actor is uh
is is better because you get perhaps
more emotional
inflection than you would otherwise yeah
yeah that is one of the reasons although
um there it depends with synthetic audio
you can do speech to speech or text to
speech with text to speech this is all
probably less not as interesting to or
maybe it is
but with with text to speech you cannot
control the cadence and emotion
as much but with speech to speech you
actually do have someone else
say the audio in the with the cadence
and emotion you want and then the ai
turns it into the person's voice
yeah when mike microsoft first did
uh language translation
uh rick rashid gave a a short piece of
his 380 talk
uh in chinese and
what he did is he spoke it to english it
was translated to text
the text was translated chinese and a
little chinese robot
uh who knew about how to speak chinese
spoke the chinese for him
and it was fast enough so it looked
seamless it was
it was quite amazing and probably just
as well that we didn't understand
chinese
but it was really quite quite amazing
and you know some of the google
translate stuff works
uh in that same that same model so it's
it's also possible that you can
you can have your mark zuckerberg
character actor speaking in french or
russian or that's true and there is a
there is a fake precedent there's a
i don't know if you're familiar with
david beckham's malaria
psa and that that's kind of like a
benevolent
you know i don't i don't even need
quotations remarks around that
it's a yeah pro-social use of deep fakes
um to take uh to take a psa
that david beckham did in english about
malaria and translate it into i think
it's eight different
languages african languages so
yeah and you know that but it does lose
something in the translation perhaps
right but um it does get out there in a
very large
to a large audience and conveys the
information
and can in fact i you know i i think
this is
a this is a mechanism for a political
change and
uh is is extremely interesting
it's almost as if um
fiction comes alive yes
and yeah it's
extremely strange to me that uh
that you know people have have been
worrying about
the the fakes in some sense
uh and the reason is that our little
alarm bells just wave flags and say
hey this is a fake right don't get
triggered right
so you take you take your your
cautionary
brackets off um it
looks pretty real yeah
yeah but that's i mean we we do we kind
of do
use kind of what we could call
purposeful fiction
in other areas of our lives right with
the placebo effect i mean the actually
doctors say that the placebo effect is
the most underutilized tool in all of
medicine
and you know and or with alternate uh or
virtual reality therapy
you know we can we even though
we know that the virtual experience is
is not real and yet it can still help us
overcome ptsd
and so there are ways to use
i mean what we might call purposeful
fiction
you know well i think fiction is is a
big part in general
yeah i watched the crown of course
i uh well actually i have watched uh
children's cartoons on airplanes yeah
which are
have a great deal to recommend them yeah
it fits my uh
my mental acuity on an airplane
no i think i think that i think this is
this is this is fascinating
can this be done at home
are you are we going to see fourth third
graders or fourth graders doing it
eventually probably which is part of why
there are different kind of deep fake
kind of
startups synthesia
is one candy ai and i think they're all
kind of hurrying
to make as much money on this as they
can because they know that
eventually it's going to be an after
effects filter
you know so i think it probably will
will be in the hands of
yeah most people of people who have
access to
these kinds of tools okay
yeah i i think i think uh
the time will come and there will be a
little a little
zoom video of somebody running for
fourth grade president class
and it will be a fake i hope i find out
about it i will be very curious to
yeah okay well um
is there anything more that you'd like
to tell us i i think i think that we
have a good idea of where you are
yeah you know i i gotta say i i think uh
i i think it's uh it's uh it's it's
wonderful i
am uh
i'm certainly not in favor of uh uh
limiting access to this sort of
technology in any way whatsoever
i i do worry about
separating truth from fiction but then
this is this is not the only place that
that happens yes
even if we eliminated all deep fakes we
would not have solved the post-truth
problem which to me is a
you know is a problem of epistemological
proportion so that's really
that's really where we need to intervene
is at the epistemological level
i would say you know it's time for
the next enlightenment okay
anyhow thank you very much i think that
we're done you this is uh this has been
a great experience for me
i hope that our audience enjoys it and
um
we'll uh have an opportunity to talk
with you at some point later i hope
thank you this is not a this is not the
last chapter of this
this novel we've got lots coming and
there may be
uh i'm i'm potentially trying
possibly to do a trump concession speech
so if i do i will let you know
do let me know i'll at least publicize
it on
on the uh our website as well and
maybe even linked to it would be a
really very nice thing
okay well thank you dennis enjoy the
rest of your weekend
thanks stephanie okay